good afternoon it's a it's a pleasure to
be here to deliver an eight hour lecture
to you in about one hour or so so i'll
see what i can do about going through
this and just to put a little bit of
perspective on this i started working in
the criminal justice system in 1989 as a
result of a class action lawsuit in
which i testified and the sort of
response to that was well alright so
you've identified that we've got some
serious problems in our prison system
and now can you try to do something
about it so not only do i wear my
doctor's stethoscope and go into the
prisons and see patients but i've been
thinking for a long time about how to
create interventions that really improve
the lives of people living with HIV who
cycle into and out of our criminal
justice system and that's not only
domestically but internationally so let
me just set the stage for here in the US
but in many places throughout the world
it is not that difference but in the
past 30 years there has been a three
hundred percent increase in growth in
our criminal justice system such that
there are 12 million people who leave
our prisons and jails each year so we
are really talking about a huge order of
magnitude and though the estimates were
higher about a decade ago where one in
four people transition through our
criminal justice system each year
there's still a significant proportion
one in six and it represents a lot of
people as part of the 1.1 million people
living with HIV in this country in other
places where I work that proportion is
higher such as in Ukraine and in
Malaysia where we have ongoing problems
contributing to this increase in growth
in the criminal justice system
domestically and we had the trans
institutionalization of patients with
mental illness basically releasing from
our mental health centers into
communities and the prisons became the
repositories for people with ongoing
mental illness you add on to that the
sort of array that was really from the
late 60s and early 70s in the
the 80s we began not we the collective
we but the we over in Washington began
its war on drugs where there was a sort
of an increased amount of incarceration
of people with substance use disorders
and those substance use disorders being
chronic and relapsing medical conditions
so we're looking so far at at least two
chronic relapsing medical conditions
which are treatable and can be treated
effectively in our community settings
but once again the sort of interface or
thus endemic with the criminal justice
system is inextricably linked but is
contributing to this increase in growth
and then of course when you have to sort
of chronic and relapsing conditions both
of which are associated with increased
risk taking behaviors and increased
prevalence of a number of infectious
diseases you see a concentration of HIV
and a number of other chronic conditions
such as viral hepatitis tuberculosis and
sti's which go into and out of our
criminal justice system so to really put
this into place we have this sort of
cyclical and interrelated effect where
you have all of these sorts of
convergence of these disorders and
within our communities we have this
underlying factor of social instability
and that can be defined really quite
broadly whether it's a part of our group
who's looking at homelessness if it's
Jamie Meyer who's looking at the impact
of interpersonal violence and a number
of these other factors which destabilize
people's lives and which contribute
independently to ongoing problems with
mental illness such as the case of
interpersonal violence and
post-traumatic stress disorder
homelessness and sort of relapse to drug
use it's really not so important to
really identify whether it's the chicken
or the egg but to really recognize that
these things must be addressed in a
synergistic sort of approach and that
just tackling one piece of the puzzle is
insufficient and then of course the way
that we begin to think about such
interventions really have to be not only
at the individual level such as the
individual with mental illness and
addressing that mental illness but we
have to have systems of care
within our our settings we have to have
community-based interventions that are
broad and wide whether they are a public
information or otherwise and then of
course we've got to have the sort of
link with the criminal justice system in
order to make all of these issues come
together now I mentioned briefly that
the proportion of patients with HIV who
transitioned to the criminal justice
system at least in 1997 represented one
out of four individuals let me just give
you a sense of what proportion of
patients with other sorts of diseases go
through such as hepatitis C where two
out of five individuals with hepatitis C
among the five million people in the
u.s. go through the criminal justice
system and the same proportion of
individuals with tuberculosis go into
the system so these are really important
places so not only to identify to begin
the treatment and to really provide
ongoing care as mentioned before the
proportion with HIV who go through has
been slightly reduced now one of the
problems that we have from a societal
perspective is we really think of these
individuals in criminal justice settings
as being out of sight and out of mind
and as though that they are not dynamic
with our community but if you really
want to think about this from a
biological perspective I think about
these as semi permeable membranes where
people cycle into and out almost like
osmosis but there's a concentration so
if you've got let's say this
concentrating effect of these infectious
diseases within the criminal justice
system and among that there's 12 million
people who are being relapsed there is
this revolving door so that there are
these concentrations these may indeed be
sites where if you identify them and you
begin the treatment it's the place at
which you can begin the interventions
that reduce the likelihood of not only
returning back to prisons but sustaining
these health outcomes because many of
the individuals who come into these
settings are unlikely to access a number
of health services and important
interventions while they are in
community settings because of indeed
their ongoing untreated or even
undiagnosed mental illness or untreated
substance use disorders I also want to
say that there are
are a number of other factors that are
going to be sin demek with us that are
not infection related that must be
addressed as well that are semi
permeable now in the case of HIV it is
absolutely critical to think about and I
think that this is a this is but one
paradigm but probably not a bad one and
that is hearses defined continuum of HIV
care and with this really suggests that
not only do individuals have to be
identified for their HIV infection so
they have to basically be tested they
have to be told that is they have to
come back for testing of course rapid
testing reduces the likelihood of not
knowing that sort of information they
have to be linked to care they have to
be retained in care ultimately so that
they are fully engaged that will allow
them to be monitored that allows them to
actually initiate antiretroviral therapy
in a timely manner and it also requires
that they be adherent to their
antiretroviral therapy so that we can
ultimately achieve viral suppression and
in idealized models from the World
Health Organization or in empiric models
from Vancouver and British Columbia we
certainly have learned that part of the
sikh test and treat strategy of getting
at least a certain proportion of
individuals in a modeling paper by
gardner or whether it's julio Montana's
model in Vancouver with thirty percent
gardeners model of sixty percent and
Rubens model from the World Health
Organization at varying different levels
we need to achieve viral suppression at
the 30 60 or 90 percent level overall so
so much much higher so how well do we do
in this country we don't do so well we
have about nineteen percent of
individuals who have viral suppression
and it's in its it's important to
recognize that the the presence of
inadequately treated substance use
disorders and mental health
independently interrupt each and every
one of these cycles with regard to
engaging and retaining individuals in
gear now while we're not going to spend
a lot of time talking about the issues
around entry what can you do to
routinely tests and diagnose a number of
conditions which part of the crib
just a setting there'll be a quiz on
which parts there are in a second and
then the provision of treatment in their
settings the sort of piece that I want
to focus on is this sort of release or
transitional issues such as adherence to
antiretroviral therapy adherence to
substance use disorder treatments and
mental illness and to examine some of
the risk reduction and linkage
strategies in general so for those of
you who you know kind of want the sort
of Reader's Digest version sandy
Springer is the lead author on a paper
that we published which looked at five
essential components which really sort
of address a number of these things it
provides the evidence for what's out
there but also really identifies where
there are significant missing gaps now
when we are thinking about implementing
an intervention it's important to
recognize that the criminal justice
system is not just the criminal justice
system it is this incredibly complicated
array and the sorts of things that one
can do let's say for instance at drug
courts or at course is very different
than what you can do with the prisoner
who may have two to three years left on
their sentence where you can begin to
implement and sustain and repeat and do
sorts of things and so what you can do
in various different settings is quite
different so briefer interventions for
some settings more intensive or more
connective ones but the piece about
transition is really about how do you
sustain them in communities no matter
where you identify them and so that's
kind of the sort of underlying piece i'm
going to start first we're talking about
prisons prisons are typically places
where people are sentenced for at least
one to two years so you've got a bit of
time to work with them and one of the
things that we know from the prison
related data is that just 15 years ago
the sort of age-related mortality or
death associated with HIV in the prisons
was over three times greater among
prisoners and in the general community
and part of that had to be issues around
access to antiretroviral therapy and
provision of evidence-based treatments
in fact I was part of that movement 15
years ago to make those sorts of changes
but by 2008 and so we've got you know
effect
therapies that work that the sort of
ability to reduce mortality was really
equilibrate adinda prison so i would say
that in many ways the prisons have done
a fairly good job at implementing what i
would call the evidence basis for
treating at least HIV now of course
these are idealized situations you can
provide directly observed therapy in
this in these settings it's incredibly
structured you know you can identify
who's going to come into your
appointments there's not the sort of
community extension sees there's not the
sort of ongoing unaddressed substance
use disorders I don't really call it
that they treat the substance use
disorders it's called forced abstinence
but nonetheless it's not mitigating the
lives of individuals in interrupting
their care so in general you can see
that at least among these individuals
who have high prevalence of substance
use disorders a mental illness you can
at least achieve parity but then the
problem is is what happens to
individuals during incarceration where
you can achieve these benefits and then
what happens to them soon after release
in a study that we did that was led by
sandy Springer she really demonstrated
that that for individuals who had
received antiretroviral therapy for at
least six months there was a markedly
significant reduction in viral load
which is what you want to do you want to
suppress the virus and then there was an
increase in cd4 cell count but within
three months or 12 weeks after release
this is an important time period you
find that essentially all of the
benefits that had happened that had
during the course of incarceration where
you have this incredible structure were
completely lost and so if one wants to
think about this in terms of framing it
in a slightly different way we looked at
individuals who had at the time of
release from prison three out of five
individuals had a suppressed viral load
so in other words and this was in 2004
this was consistent with what we were
finding in community settings so once
again the prison was doing pretty good
in terms of its grade card but within
three months only one out of five had a
non-detectable viral load or maximal
suppression suggesting one of two things
that they were either one being
incompletely adherent to therapy or they
were not being retained in care another
they were lost completely now there's a
number of factors that people have
looked at in terms of what might have an
impact in a series of studies that was
done by kinloch and others in maryland
they really tried to study this is not
in patients with HIV by the way but they
looked at individuals who were within
this prison setting who had opioid
dependence and they looked at a number
of outcomes and they randomized them to
either just get counseling that you
should reduce your drug use they either
then it would either kind of add to that
they would get counseling and then they
would get transferred they'd get a
voucher and says okay you can go to a
methadone program when you get out and
you get in now of course there may be
some problems with that there's all of
the sorts of things that happen as
people leave the prison on the first day
of prison release you think well what
would do people do they're going to run
out they're going to get their HIV care
they're going to get their substance use
a treatment and things like that and the
answer is no they're going to get a
McDonald's Big Mac and get laid and so
when you think about the sort of
priorities that people have as their
kind of leaving prison and whether
methadone is somewhere on those sort of
hierarchy of needs it's somewhat lower
but for the individuals who started the
treatment and got a transfer upon
release so they started their treatment
of method M you can say that you can see
that in terms of being retained in
treatment it's significantly higher the
proportion who entered a treatment
overall and who completed treatment was
significantly different now this one
year completion rate is somewhat lower
than we would like to see because it's
lower than what we see in community
settings in terms of being retained on
methadone treatment and there's a number
of other factors that may go into this
and that if you're thinking about slowly
getting an opioid agonist on board
getting them up to what I would call a
therapeutic dose within a time frame
there was insufficient time to get them
to levels and I'll speak a little bit
more to that in just a second what I
will say however among these individuals
is that there were eight deaths among
the 204 patients in this study six of
them were due to overdose then these are
in non hiv-infected patients but you can
imagine the interface with HIV and
substance use disorders is high and two
of them were cardiovascular there were
none in the patients who were on
methadone so methadone was markedly
protective of over
goes in death in these individuals so
getting to the point of why the
retention rate was so low at thirty six
point seven percent jeff wickersham from
our group in a study that we're doing in
malaysia evaluated data from a pilot
methadone program where we put patients
on methadone up to six months before
release they could be as early as three
months and you can increase by about
five milligrams a week so you can
imagine you can get two different
therapeutic levels of methadone by the
time that you're released and if you
stratify based upon the evidence for
effective treatment with methadone by
getting doses of 80 milligrams or more
or a lower dose of methadone you can see
that the retention in methadone drops
off almost immediately and is
significantly different but that the
levels are actually somewhat even lower
than that thirty-six percent that you
see in the kinloch study among the
individuals who had lower doses of
methadone but overall if you average
that out you get at about the forty-five
percent range not that different than
the thirty-six percent range so overall
the ideas that you may have to start
earlier getting them up to therapeutic
levels before you transition them to the
community now those are data among
prisoners in whom you have a little bit
more time to begin to work with and so
in a ten site study that was funded by
her sir to examine community models of
transitional programs for hiv-infected
jail detainees we're one of the ten
sites that's looking at this but among
the multi-site study there are about
twelve hundred and seventy hiv-infected
individuals who are in this in who
enrolled in the study we excluded
individuals who were reincarnated or who
were sentenced to prison so in other
words they didn't have the chance of
getting out into the community and so
this still leaves well over 800
individuals and what we wanted to look
at is we wanted to look at differing
measures of retention in care because
remember as I pointed out along the HOH
IV continuum of care model it is
required that a person be retained in
care so that they can be monitored and
then eventually get antiretroviral
therapy and what you can and what we did
was we defined as retention in care is
having an HIV visit
that was linked to having a viral load
test and that's one of the things that
we expect HIV providers to do whenever
you see someone and monitor them for
their HIV disease and as you can see
right off the bat two out of five
individuals are completely lost to care
and we'll take a look at some of the
sort of correlates of that particular
group because the correlates for that
group associated with loss to care
completely is really having untreated
substance use disorders alcohol use
disorders mostly opioids interestingly
enough and and also having untreated
mental illness we then looked at three
other measures of retention earlier
retention that is they had a doctor's
visit in a viral load within the first
quarter after release delayed retention
was we lost him for a while but we
eventually got him back in and then we
looked at sustained retention which is
basically monitoring every three months
and that is the group who about one out
of three individuals and at least among
the idealized situation where we want to
have patience it's this sort of
sustained retention in care and the
independent correlates of being retained
in care for six months including
included being of male gender not
relapsing to drugs or alcohol during
that time period receiving a pre-release
planning program so in other words to
say these are the things that you need
and these are how you go get it but they
didn't actually do anything after
release and then also getting a post
release disease management session and
so by definition this group at least had
to get seen afterwards but remember we
lose forty percent overall and they're
slightly different so whether it's
prison or jails it's really important I
talked about the the hamburger and
getting laid on the day of release what
ends up happening is is despite the
best-laid intentions of identifying what
all of the things are real life
unfortunately gets in the way whether
it's studying for your exams or all of
these other sorts of things let's see
it's Friday night and it's margarita
party or whatever it is these sorts of
things all interfere in the sort of
decision making and so what ends up
happening and for many individuals is
that they are derailed from getting this
sort of linkage to care the first sort
of derailment
occurs with this incredibly high risk of
death of former inmates Ingrid
binswanger who was formerly at the
Washington who's now at the University
of Colorado looked at statewide data
which showed that the overall mortality
was 3.5 times higher for release
prisoners than the general population
and she looked at mortality at one year
after release but the mortality was
highest that is 12.5 times higher not
3.5 times higher in the first two weeks
post release and so this is where
relapse is the highest so you can
imagine like just getting to your HIV
appointment when you relapse the drugs
and alcohol is going to certainly
interfere with that and the increased
mortality was associated with a handful
of conditions overdose being HIV
infected homicide being in a motor
vehicle accident maybe perhaps under the
influence of alcohol or drugs having
cancer and having liver disease and HIV
having a substance use disorder and
liver disease are all independently
concentrated among the criminal justice
system well just not to say that
Washington is different in a
meta-analysis of six different studies
both domestic and international studies
drug-related deaths accounted for fifty
percent of des overall and once again it
confirmed in the meta-analysis that the
highest risk of death with it was it
within the first two weeks so confirming
Ingrid's findings which really and most
of these deaths are related to opioids
and so these are really the only ones
that really cause overdose and death so
it really has important implications for
medication assisted therapy among
prisoners transitioning to the community
in the same way that the kinloch data
that I presented earlier earlier was
protective of death among release
programs so some of the factors that
have been examined over the course of
years looking at what might be
contributing to the sort of poor HIV
treatment outcomes Jodi rich identified
that the loss of medication or medical
entitlements when one comes into prison
or jail contributes to it and there's
usually a delayed process
fact it's almost perverse in 39 out of
our 50 states currently that if you get
incarcerated for more than 30 days the
Department of Social Services will pay
the Department of Correction four
hundred dollars to give them the name so
that they will take you off of the
social security roles so that you can be
disenrolled from your insurance and so
if you're in for 31 days you get removed
from these roles and it requires
oftentimes six to eight weeks to get
reinstated and since most of our
patients with HIV are getting their sort
of medical entitlements through the
public domain these are individuals who
have to go back to that process in order
to get reinstated and that includes for
our aids drug assistance program
whatsoever the next step is they need to
get a medical appointment and a
prescription to continue their
medications often times there are
waiting lists in our HIV clinics in
order to do that and you're oftentimes
released with only a two-week supply of
medication if anything at all there are
issues around adherence and retention in
care that impede that outcome and then
of course more recently how can you
intervene in order to really sustain
viral suppression through adherence
interventions so we saw with the jail
study that that actually having a
pre-release discharge planning was
actually one of the significant factors
associated with sustained retention in
care however in another study looking at
what they call strengths-based case
management and I'm always a little
anxious when I use the word case
management because I'm not really sure I
know what it means everybody uses a term
for it and it means a hundred different
things to a hundred different people
even though you have a construct because
every case manager who does this job
typically does it well but they have
their own ideas about the way that they
do that we try to define it we try to
make it you know sort of structured but
people's lives are not so structured so
people do what they want but compared to
no discharge planning data have really
demonstrated that results in higher
receipt of first HIV
appointment but not in sort of retention
in care and so we really have to figure
out ways that it might impact continuous
engagement and a number of HIV treatment
outcomes but in a study from North
Carolina where they use the strengths
based case management versus the
standard of care which was a pre-release
sort of meeting saying these are what
your unmet needs are this is what you
need to do here's the place that you go
they really found that with regard to
the the proportion who is not in medical
care over time it was actually no
different than having a group of
individuals and this was actually post
release a transitional care versus the
standard of care which was the
pre-release meeting it had no impact or
doing anything different now they
published this state of these data but
the people who actually did the study
said you know one of the problems that
they're community-based case managers
had was they said so we sent them out
and we identified that they had needs a
through z but there were not the sort of
community resources that were available
so this sort of enabling resources that
are required to get people into
substance abuse treatment they had no
treatment actually for cocaine which was
their primary drug there so that these
individuals had no difference with
regard to do it so they could actually
do and say you need to get an
appointment here you need to get an
appointment here but you don't have the
insurance and there was really not
anything for them to do so they were
kind of struck by the sort of inability
to have the sort of enabling resources
in the community there were a number of
other outcomes that were examined with
regard to follow up visits in which
there was no difference emergency room
use Andrey incarceration so at 12 months
one out of three individuals were
reincarnated in a study that was done
from the great state of Texas some I'll
take that back just the state of Texas
they actually looked at it's got one of
the largest hiv-infected populations
whatsoever they actually looked at over
2,000 individuals who were released they
had a sort of computerized a tap program
where you could get a you got a 10 day
supply of medications as you are
released and then you could go and
access antiretroviral therapy if you
were able to get to one of the selected
farm
that was on the list so you would say
well gosh these people are doing
relatively well within prisons and so
they would be highly motivated in order
to get therapy it was slightly
complicated that if you think about it
they're going to run out of medications
within ten days so they've got kind of
this 10-day window kind of ticking away
in order to get their medications but
only one out of 20 individuals actually
got their medications refill within that
time so then you say okay they're going
to be off medications for at least 20
days well only one out of five
individuals and one out of three
individuals had gotten their medications
refilled within 60 days now what they
did show in a secondary analysis was
that for the individuals who got case
management services after release they
were three times more likely to access
their antiretroviral therapy because the
case managers can help them through this
incredibly complex system of finding the
right pharmacy in order to get their
medications so once again this community
sort of connection is absolutely
critical and so the best-laid things on
paper don't necessarily translate to
people actually utilizing them because
the systems are complicated it looked
beautiful on paper the plan looked
beautiful on paper but the reality was
people would get out they didn't know
where to do it the piece of paper had
been removed from them they got released
at at court their paperwork was taken
away so let's talk a little bit about
how might the relapse to drug and
alcohol use actually have an impact on a
number of these sort of outcomes we
recently finished a randomized
controlled trial we had demonstrated a
few years ago and is one of the
evidence-based adherence interventions
that directly administered
antiretroviral therapy is an effective
intervention for individuals with
substance use disorders and we thought
about this that HIV infected prisoners
have high rates of substance use
disorders and can we sustain the benefit
after release from prison by putting
them on directly observed therapy to
really transition them back to the
community and we compared that to them
just getting a 14-day supply and
transitional case management as part of
this the dart or the directly observed
therapy was provided once day
seven days per week because we recognize
that our patients did not come with a
single disorder they often had mental
illness hypertension and array of other
things all of their prescriptions for
other chronic conditions were also
coadministered at the same time and then
we nested within this study individuals
who met pre incarceration diagnosis for
opioid dependence that is they had had a
diagnosis of opioid dependence when they
came in recognizing that overlap
overdose and death was incredibly high
for these individuals and so we offered
it to them on the day of release as part
of their relapse prevention all subjects
received standard case management
services across the board that was
universally applied and there's no
difference we eventually enrolled 154
subjects which we randomized to 212 the
d-o-t over the self administer therapy
we randomized a higher proportion to the
d-o-t because we were concerned that
there may be a group of individuals who
did not want people butting into their
life as it turns out there were not very
many people who were unwilling to
participate and we had a retention rate
that exceeded eighty-five percent so we
did very very well with regard to
following these individuals as you can
see this is a fairly ill population with
regard to other comorbidities about
sixty percent overall met criteria for
opioid dependence ninety percent met
criteria for cocaine abuse or dependence
and about thirty three percent overall
met criteria for alcohol dependence
almost half of the individuals met
criteria using the mini for having an
axis one disorder they did a good job in
prison eighty percent had a
non-detectable viral load by the time
that they released so it's even higher
than it was in 2004 and I think part of
that may be that we've got better
simplified regimens with which patients
can take and the cd4 count was
relatively restored at 350 to 400 and
cells so they were they were leaving in
fairly good shape but they had a lot of
comorbidity that they were at risk for
relapsing and what you can see using a
couple of different measures for outcome
what we call viral suppression at less
than 400 copies or maximal viral
suppression at less than 50 there was a
significant difference in individuals in
the d-o-t group versus the s80 and
remember about 80% had a non-detectable
viral load at the time of release it is
essentially unchanged at six months for
the less than 400 copies and that was
similarly true at the less than 50
copies these patients were maximally
suppressed at the time of leaving their
cd4 cell count was at a plateau so we
didn't really expect much of a
difference so there's a non significant
difference with regard to t cells which
are actually also much more highly
variable so the question is is does the
intervention work and the answer is yes
what we are still analyzing the data to
figure out is is the benefit sustained
when we discontinue it and one of the
things that we learned about our
community based intervention was that it
worked as long as you did the
intervention but afterwards it did not
what we did in this study is we built in
a transitional program where we trained
individuals to fill their own pill boxes
and we're hoping when we look at the
12-month outcomes or the six-month
post-intervention outcomes that we
actually have a sustained benefit but
those data are not available when we
want to take a look at the correlates of
achieving the primary outcome or
dependent variable of having a viral
suppression at less than 400 copies
being on directly observed therapy
portended a three-fold increased
likelihood of having an undetectable
viral load individuals who started out
with suppressed virus irrespective of
their arms were five times more likely
to sustain their viral load that
suggesting that whatever they were able
to do in prison or jail they were able
to hold it together afterwards so they
were really kind of maximizing their
virus viral suppression by probably
being a little bit more adherent if they
had an alcohol use disorder however it
pretended about a sixty four percent
decrease likelihood in achieving viral
suppression and then of course
individuals who were prescribed to
buprenorphine
and stayed on it for six months were
three and a half times more likely to
kind of achieve viral suppression so it
has not only implications for the
treatment of alcohol use disorders but
that there is a benefit from using a
evidence-based treatment for opioid
dependence in terms of reducing the
likelihood of not achieving a viral
suppression so it's the notion that
treating the substance use disorder
itself is an effective way at improving
the viral load outcome so you've got the
intervention of do t which is
independent and the treatment of a
substance use disorder as being
independent factors associated with a
positive outcome and the non treatment
of another alcohol use disorder as being
a negative correlate so it has it really
incredible implications and I just want
to point out that what we do have that's
available and that is part of our
evidence for the treatment of opioid
dependence includes the methadone which
we solve from the kinloch study I'm
going to show you a little bit of data
and our data on buprenorphine as a
partial opioid agonist and antagonist
and then some new implications for
long-acting or extended release nel trek
zone which is a pure opioid antagonist
and the reason why this Nell trek zone
has some interesting implications for
the future because a lot of these
patients of alcohol use disorders and
opioid dependence is that this
injectable naltrexone is has evidence
for being the most effective treatment
for alcohol use disorders so in patients
who've got two disorders you can
potentially attack it with one single
injection once a month and so I think
that in terms of the armamentarium of
what we have out there we might be able
to simplify it for a handful of patients
and that's one of the things that we're
beginning to look at in places such as
Eastern Europe where everybody who uses
opioids also has a drinking problem and
we can potentially treat what does it
kill two birds with one stone as it were
so here are some data from the community
which we first applied to see what we
could figure out with regard to treating
the
OPI the opioid dependence in the setting
of HIV and this is a multi-site study of
nearly 300 hiv-infected patients who
started buprenorphine at 10 clinical
sites there's nothing magical about 10
that's just what hersha seems to fund in
the other sort of study and we found
that buprenorphine treatment increased
the likelihood of not only initiating
antiretroviral therapy and improving the
cd4 cell count but interestingly enough
did not have any impact on viral
suppression and part of that reason was
that over sixty percent of patients were
already on antiretroviral therapy and
doing relatively well so that we weren't
really able among 300 patients to see
much of a difference among that other
group we then stratified the analyses
based upon those who were on and not on
antiretroviral therapy at baseline and
not being on antiretroviral therapy was
associated with being younger having
alcohol use problems being homeless
having a higher viral load and reporting
increased risk behaviors really
suggesting the importance of coming up
with interventions that focuses on these
most challenging individuals in the
community and what we did was when we
stratify this as we said alright what it
probably takes from a clinical
perspective is that a a clinician has
got to be comfortable that they're
actually taking care of their substance
use disorder before they initiate their
antiretroviral therapy because they're
concerned upfront because of adherence
problems and it's been demonstrated in a
number of studies that if you're
actively using drugs or alcohol you're
less likely to take your antiretroviral
therapy perfectly and so what you can
see is that for individuals who were
retained on buprenorphine for three or
four quarters somewhere over six months
period of time you were significantly
more likely to get onto antiretroviral
therapy and for the first time we begin
to see a sort of a viral suppression
among the people who were not on
antiretroviral therapy achieve parity
with the group who was already on before
so what it's really doing in terms of
its driving its outcome is it's driving
its
outcome among the individuals who were
not on antiretroviral therapy and then
the achievement of viral suppression is
similar once you can keep a person on
buprenorphine for longer so retention on
treatment is not just getting the
treatment but being retained on the
substance abuse treatment is really
quite critical now these studies were
going on in parallel but the sort of
idea was sort of percolating and in an
r21 that we did that was the nested
study within our do t study we wanted to
assess the acceptability and the
feasibility of initiating buprenorphine
in patients who would not use drugs for
years as part as they were transitioning
to the community what we did was we
created the first protocol for
buprenorphine induction that occurred on
the day of release and we could actually
enroll them up to 30 days after release
and these standardized protocols were
set up for those who were on do t and
not on a do t so that they would either
get them once a day observed or weekly
and the data from the first 12 weeks and
this is remember as I pointed out
earlier on this is the critical time
after release where patients began to
fall apart and what you can see here is
that that that despite the fact that
that patients had been incarcerated for
quite some time years in some cases
their craving for opioids was actually
quite high it was a 62 opioids I mean
yes there's a few patients in prison who
have access to opioids if you happen to
be in Ukraine there's a high proportion
of your patients who've had access to
opioids but what we found was that
within three days of starting the
buprenorphine this craving response in
Sandy Springer's leading this sort of
move but is you know isn't the craving
that's driving the relapse and can you
use that as your sort of marker we
haven't figured that out yet and that's
part of her ongoing sort of work but it
reduced the craving within three days
from an average of six to one we were
able because these patients were not
dependent to give by with lower doses of
buprenorphine 9 milligrams instead of
the standard 6 16 milligrams of course
anytime you enroll someone in a study
and you're nice to them
they have high satisfaction not
surprising but the retention rate at 12
weeks was seventy-four percent but then
let's translate that and this was
irrespective of whether they got do t or
self-administered therapy the proportion
of patients who had a non-detectable
viral load was equivalent suggesting
that if you treat their substance use
disorder during this time period that
it's actually effective at them
continuing to take their medications and
it was not dependent upon whether they
got do t or not and of course their t
cells remained quite good now this these
data have been expanded sandy has a
paper under review looking beyond that
12-week mark and what you see our data
that are pretty similar to what you see
in community-based people nor Fein
programs at about six months retentions
about fifty percent so that's what you
get and that's what we got so we feel as
though at least there's some sort of
face validity and then we took a look at
these hundred or so it's just a little
under a hundred individuals and we
looked at the independent correlates of
having maximum viral suppression at six
months and lo and behold at least among
the individuals who met criteria for
opioid dependence the d.o.t wasn't even
significant at all so that's probably
not what you need what we did find was
that if you were able to retain them on
buprenorphine it resulted in a over a
five fold increased likelihood of having
maximum viral suppression men had an
easier go of it as well being of African
American or being a black race
unfortunately resulted in about an
eighty-six percent reduction in
likelihood of being sustained there was
no difference in the multivariate
analysis if you were of Hispanic
ethnicity the months of incarceration
really was borderline significant if you
were virally suppressed at the time of
release once again that's independent
and then of course individuals on the
physical composite of the quality of
life module the sf-12 those individuals
were two times more likely to have a
non-detectable viral load so there's an
array of other sort of
you're suggesting that we need to do a
better job at coming up with the outcome
I will say that most of our sort of do t
outreach workers we did have one woman
who was part of that we had a number of
latino men and so that may actually in
some way reflect the differences in
terms of how people related to each
other culturally so what do we have
that's on the docket that we're actually
studying right now to figure out whether
we can find some some we can actually
fill in some of the gaps and some of the
holes so we showed that having an
alcohol use disorder resulted in a sixty
four percent decrease likelihood of an
HIV treatment outcome we're using the
same population and conducting a
randomized placebo-controlled trial of
extended-release nel trek zone for
individuals with HIV and who have
alcohol use disorders we are doing a
similar study in Connecticut and in
Massachusetts among individuals with HIV
and who have opioid dependence
ultimately we'd like to put in a
protocol in Ukraine to do that who have
both disorders we have moved the study
outside of the prison and jail release
and we're doing a randomized controlled
trial and I put extended-release
naltrexone for opioid dependence in
Community Corrections but that's that's
wrong it's actually buprenorphine in
that particular group we have a
randomized controlled trial of methadone
plus or minus a behavioral intervention
HHR p which is the holistic health
recovery project that we have adapted
for malaysia and you saw some of the
preliminary data from the dose of
methadone in that study we're almost at
200 individuals enrolled in that study
and then we are about to initiate the
first pilot study of medication assisted
therapy among prisoners with opioid
dependence in Ukraine and to do similar
sorts of studies with regard to
individuals who have tuberculosis
including multidrug-resistant
tuberculosis who are transitioning
to the community and we are also
examining the use of extended-release
nail treks own in terms of how you
organize services in Russia we have a
randomized control trial where we are
the sort of systems of care is not it's
different and it's the same in Russia
where you have individuals who cannot
get access to any sort of substitution
therapy like buprenorphine or methadone
the one medication assisted therapy that
they do have available there is
naltrexone and we're studying if the
place that you give the therapy if you
integrate it does it actually have an
impact and we have three study arms in
this particular study we're looking at
whether you take a person who is now
absent they've gone through detox and
they get injectable naltrexone and then
they continue to get their indexable
naltrexone from their HIV doctors in the
HIV clinic so it's co-located they're
getting everything at one site or if you
just treat their substance use disorder
and say hey go across town and get your
HIV care does that result in the same
sort of outcome or the sort of standard
of care because medication assisted
therapy is not part of the routine
standard of care in Russia it's about
abstinence-based counseling therapy only
and we're studying that with referral to
the HIV center as well so those are our
current projects that are underway this
is sort of a framework for thinking
about individuals that the older
environment if you will where they're
kind of walking and it's supposed to be
somebody walking the proverbial
tightrope where their life is chaotic
and somewhat disturbed they kind of land
in prison which is this artificial
environment where they get basic needs I
won't say that they're good but they do
get food I call it the one pound a day
place everybody who gets incarcerated
gains a pound a day including the
doctors who go there and they get a
shelter so they're off the streets not
that it's nice shelter in fact would you
feel those gates closing behind you it's
not the sort of sound that one likes and
then in some cases people actually say
they feel safer
and you know it's really a sad state of
our sort of community system where
people say that they go to prison in
order to feel safe again so that they
can take care of their sort of health
needs but for many people it's not safe
there are gangs and there are other
sorts of things there's exposure to
tuberculosis but it's a place where you
can begin to to provide psychiatric care
medical care antiretroviral therapy you
can create behavioral interventions but
the key feature with this is
transitioning this as they transition to
the community because without doing that
we are going to have the continued
revolving door what I think we have to
do is we have to think more broadly
because one of the things that none of
us do is we think about a jail we think
about a prison but we don't think about
this sort of complexity of criminal
justice as individuals leave jail and
maybe go to probation or leave prison
and maybe go to parole or we're trying
to divert people out of prison in jail
and putting them into alternatives to
incarceration etc but how do we link the
criminal justice with our community
supervision and our systems of care in
communities and I think that that is
sort of the mix level of thinking that
the next generation of questions are
going to need to do and so the extent to
which we have to think about this is a
very holistic sort of approach and what
are all of the sorts of things that
people are facing as they slip off this
slippery slope issues such as
homelessness relapse to drugs sometimes
we think of families as being very
stabilizing and helpful I have many
patients who tell us that their families
are part of their relapse to drug use
their untreated undiagnosed mental
illness intimate partner violence
overdose and of course the HIV risk
behaviors which are going to result in
increase transmission to communities and
if we don't get this right we are going
to perpetuate this incredible revolving
door this sort of industrial complex of
the criminal justice system which is
really unabated at this point we have
shown for the first time that the number
of people
in prison and jail finally did decrease
in 2009 but it's flattening out just a
little bit and we have to do more in
order to beef up our communities in
order to address the incredibly complex
needs of the most vulnerable people who
are living with HIV